citizens of the reject Nation it is John
it is a Roxy and we are back for yet
another installment of the Ip Man
franchise it Man 3 starring Donald the
Yen Roxy thank you for joining me how
are you today can you do your theory
thing that you do three yeah and I even
got the r roll how are you doing today
are you feeling good I I sent Greg a
text message lying to him saying that I
watched this beforehand to see if he
would freak out
and he did good
it was a lie though I haven't seen it
yet but I've been patiently waiting I
loved it man one I loved it man too I'm
gonna be very upset if this isn't good
absolutely we if it's not good we Riot
but before we find out whether it's good
or not I think you guys could at least
do us a favor and leave a like on the
video as well subscribe to the channel
hit that notification Bell And subscribe
to the World Girls follow Roxy on social
media find out everything she's doing if
you want to be with us in the present
why don't you come over to patreon.com
the real reject sync up with your own
copy of Hitman 3 enjoy all the things
that don't make these reaction
highlights the real blast over there are
you ready to do this oh yeah oh yeah
action time
this is weird martial arts Kool-Aid man
yeah we're gonna do the action
[Music]
Mike Tyson that's right I wonder how
he's gonna fit into this world The
Hangover
not this movie hey you never know
always training
always keeping those Basics strong
of all three of the movies started with
him on this yeah device that you and I
don't know what it's called people
commented and I and I should have pulled
it for this exact occasion but thank you
for letting us know
I mean another one
[Laughter]
um
yeah so Bruce Lee time
I hate it it's okay you can't be perfect
whoa
smoke fight even the cigarette can be
Kung Fu
wow
oh
[Laughter]
Wowie
okay fire
y
that's the question
very philosophical question well almost
Batman him
hmm
was that a no Legend it's a no for now
are you a die-hard Bruce Lee fan I got a
big respect for Bruce Lee definitely
seen some iconic fights but I haven't
seen a lot of full Bruce Lee films
actually me neither I've seen a lot more
Jackie Chan
oh
[Music]
oh yeah
manga
it's busy working all day what's a
rickshaw polar I think Rickshaw is one
of those carts that you you know hold on
to and run with yeah
oh he's hungry
oh little guy yeah you could see how he
was looking at it
I wonder how that's gonna sit with his
pride something that would never happen
in the states they give your kid to
another family you know just go home and
have dinner with these folks for a while
No One's Gonna sue us for kidnapping
negligence
foreign
[Music]
they found like the most gorgeous actors
of all time for these movies
oh
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
oh here we go
it's a smart move of Mike Tyson to be in
this movie oh sure do you notice that
Master app is living in luxury again or
at least comfortably yeah I'm glad for
him me too
open it up okay
you did good what about that other
business
foreign
bet your ass it is whoa no the people in
the comments also told me that Wing Chun
was invented by a woman yeah named for
her and now a priestess if I'm not
mistaken thank you rejects
oh no no
yeah
she deserves a date
the best wife in the world
[Laughter]
we've all had that moment
[Music]
a lifelong dabbler
this guy's got a lot to prove yeah
[Music]
normally
between the two of us
oh dude
ah dude
laughs
gonna miss your kid
[Music]
make a sternly worded call your boss
here they are total thugs
um
appreciate your help
teach them outside in the streets
foreign
we got that look yeah Love Is in the Air
Haunted Mansion
this haunted room actually stretching
unbelievable voice you just did dead
ringer
oh
come on
hmm
[Laughter]
oh
damn it
oh my God what do they have in their
hands gasoline probably
Why I oughta
oh damn
whoa no
leave this poor man alone
they're just trying to teach the kids
God every time he does that I know I
can't even move that quickly I know
right I feel like I just did good
I'm gonna watch your skills grow over
these reactions
like how do you smoke cigarettes and do
that your stamina is unbelievable yeah
it's like training in the mountains
nice I really like this guy's Style
[Laughter]
he's awesome yeah
[Music]
caught in those like dual kicks yeah
what time is it
I mean I guess people always need
transport but yeah
think about Ubers
o all right I don't know if this is
luxury but you know but nice nicer than
the whole from last time yes
oh someone's not getting laid tonight
don't miss a date I know man heels are
so many dates yeah
if
[Music]
damn I don't like her she was so judgy I
know
he's a hard worker clearly keeps his
head down too the investigation into the
school I will take care of it because I
am in charge because I am the most
British man who's ever lived and
therefore I am evil
what
foreign
oh
damn
yeah
you've done it
huh uh no no
foreign
[Music]
auntie
how do I join
oh
bad luck do you think that was an improv
moment yeah I bet that was I don't think
you meant to do that I bet they just
kept it because it was real yeah
she deserves
the biggest bestest date of all time
after all this is done like what are you
thinking
like I don't know
some kind of magical foreign getaway
maybe all she wants is a little dance
class
Little Things
did he just leave a tip
[Music]
he's asking for another favor it's not a
tip at all yeah
she's so into the paper
[Laughter]
that's funny yes that's a good clap back
yeah I was gonna guess that no
who can she talk to feel so bad for us
like she deserves a break from all this
anguish
go to him
to him don't suffer in silence
oh damn it
oh don't go to the dark side
of this full of bills they're all like
different sizes I know yeah like how
much is that really
no dude
no
of course what a shot yeah
I hate this yeah
oh no oh use the umbrellas as Weapons
yeah
ah
get in the music
hated that hated it hate it hate it good
storytelling I hate it I hope there's a
Redemption Arc somewhere there's gonna
be that guy because he's not evil and
that wouldn't be an Ant-Man movie
huh
you missed last words
and your wife is not well
oh he's going to find out here
these [__]
[Music]
no that's how they get you don't don't
watch the Nickelodeon
[Music]
run oh my God they're just they're just
wholesale swiping them up oh
dude
[__] you've been had
um
[Music]
no no no no no no no no no no
what happened
[Music]
foreign
let's get it done
like his son's on the line you think
he's gonna mess it up this time
nah man he's in the zone
[Music]
yeah drink up that motivation that kid
is probably scared shitless oh yeah
[Music]
finally call him son no he didn't no I'm
just I'm waiting for him to finally call
him son yeah his disciple what you call
your your pupils always I think it's
just indicative of what kind of
relationship they have yeah damn this is
like a a boat in construction like the
hull of an unbuilt ship
it's cool
wow
oh nice this is messed up man
dude yes
go go yes you knew he wasn't gonna be
bad [__] you knew
[Music]
nice
I love this guy yeah and just the I hate
that I feel dead but yeah it's like the
way it fights you can feel the grace and
this guy you could just feel the impact
yeah like very like raw
in that bright red coat Jesus kids are
just so helpless yeah
okay
[Music]
yes yes
oh
geez yeah get high
The High Ground
kick him kick him
please it's like Papa's trying homie
yeah
wow
yes I guess maybe this makes up for
missing the date sure
saving our son's life from 150 plus
assassins
oh boy
oh nice
oh yeah I'm getting out of here
I'm just gonna take myself out
yet
[Music]
real [__] show huh
let him go
can't the kids say like he helped yeah
step up little ones
[Music]
I would cry too yeah this kid's got to
be traumatized he's gonna PTSD for the
rest of his life
[Music]
oh boy that's that was a tough moment
yeah
come on
it's not really your fault you're a
protector of the people and it probably
will happen again unfortunately yeah and
you can't even say I promise it was the
last time yeah he says it was my fault
poor thing
she's like probably going through the
same thought process right now which is
like I cannot stand what you did that
you got our son almost injured but then
you saved him and also I'm super sick
and I haven't told you and now doesn't
feel like the right time and I realize
that things are messed up the way things
are run around here but also you don't
have to fight every battle
I don't want to sew on your goddamn
button
so
[Music]
hold on
authentic oh poor thing she is a great
actress
foreign
[Music]
enough how sad I am right now about this
should be my favorite character from the
beginning even though like she's not
like the biggest part of the plot like
she just has like such presence and
Grace and she is like the ink Rock yeah
these movies do such a great job mixing
in like real things real drama yeah yeah
real life
[Music]
it's nice to see them together yeah
after so long this is horrible that's
what it took time being all this
nefarious Vice and Corruption that you
people too love to engage yourself in
you'll have to take a Hiatus otherwise
frankham Frank here I can't I almost
forgot Mike Tyson was in this movie yeah
he's had like three lines yep
koi
oh oh Christ
not oh my God
ah you uptake these
wow
God
such a tight space we haven't seen
something like this yet
Jesus
no
the helmet yes
protect there goes the best damn husband
this country's ever seen
well
those little punch zooms
oh
whoa wow
oh in his mind he's like you try to hurt
my sick wife I kill you yeah you mess
with the wrong dude
it's another casual day as it man I mean
it does seem like this is what his life
is like
the people challenging him or else major
crime that needs intervened upon
goody
going right to the top let's see who
fists are the fastest
yours a mind some fun Joe if you laugh
by then often go away
the ADR props for for doing the
interlinguals with him but also yeah
wow
Ace
that's a hard you just got such a power
punch man like yeah
Iron Mike
yeah oh damn dude
whoa whoa oh no
careful kiddo
wow
sure
somebody ever did that in real life it
would be very intimidating yeah I feel
like that's not as common as it used to
be oh he gets so far down Get Low
can you do that probably not right now
but I'm gonna practice
whoa interesting
[Music]
ah nice yes yes oh
ouch
ouch like he hit all that glass of
nothing yeah
that's right work it out
[Music]
wow whoa
got your nuts dusted right there
I feel like it was in Tyson's contract
he was like I don't have to win but I
can't lose yeah that look he gave him
just then too
yes
why don't you come in and train and you
can meet them that way because women
don't train what don't you understand I
know silly of me
foreign
[Music]
journalistic Integrity very important
whoa boy oh my
God
wow
God the way this dude moves oh he got
his bell wrong yeah
got your wish
God the way the camera work has evolved
is fascinating yeah and the colors yeah
two
wow what a what a meanwhile montage
where is this command how is he here
every time yeah
yeah this is personal photographer now
is the Jimmy Olsen of kung fu he calls
him be there in five yes
a little
um
foreign
I want it man to say no my wife is sick
I don't feel like fighting today caring
for my wife is the true Wing Chun okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's pretty funny that's a good one I
love when people in movies tell jokes
and when they're actually funny yeah
Good Will Hunting sitting at the table
mini driver these foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
so you think they haven't told their kid
yeah I don't think they've told him yet
okay what age do you do that I don't
know some of these experimental
treatments gotta work
jeez man I do love the contrast of of
the side by side In this passage with
Chung On The Rise and IP just living
family life
or hormone
interesting I didn't open the door so
you'd leave I guess so that you'd feel
free to come in at any time okay my door
is open too maybe
but did it man even accept
I feel like he could easily just not
show up to this
foreign
[Music]
yes yes
who cares miss the fight dance it up I
love it
[Music]
this is great great character
development I mean I know we come to
these for the amazing fights largely but
I I'm so happy just to watch them damn
like I watch a new wave movie of them
just dancing and living life yeah yeah
this other dude's gonna feel so
disrespected
[Music]
by technicality
de facto winner
traditionalist
s are 18.
interesting
wow that was a clever way to twist it
yeah
oh no
[Applause]
no no
[Music]
oh no whoa
it's a deafening silence
it's good they got that dancing but yeah
[Music]
how are you
never gonna make it out yeah I'm gonna
keep holding out hope that one of these
like treatments they've sought will work
but I don't I don't
think that's what's gonna happen oh
they're not doing anything this is why
Superman works best when his dad dies of
a heart attack and not when he could
have saved his dad it's like you know we
there's nothing he can do
sure it is very uh you just have to kind
of
accept the present moment we've seen him
win every single fight but this isn't a
fight yeah you can't bargain with this
yeah
because we kept wondering like you know
at some point it man has to lose right
oh well yeah and and in the way you
didn't think he was right yeah oh
oh dressed up one more time
[Music]
oh
got it
[Music]
so you think she's gonna die and then
he's gonna fight I guess that's how the
structure is feeling right now
I wonder what she put in that note
though or do you think he's gonna fight
and she's gonna see him win one last
time she passes away while he's fighting
oh
[Music]
yeah
that's a bar let me show you let's see
okay
show you
later
and to Wing Chun
[Music]
oh sure
how single does this movie make you feel
quite we should all be so lucky to have
a love like this boy
nice that's what was in the letter
[Music]
oh
she's so supportive and perfect that's
beautiful a couple goals serious she
knows she's leaving the Earth and she's
like what am I leaving him with
yeah all he's gonna have is his wooden
man and uh and the kids but you know
she's not the same yeah where is the kid
we don't know
[Music]
whatever this instrument is to like is
one of the most beautiful and
heartbreaking sounds like it almost
sounds like a voice but I feel like it's
some kind of string sounds like a what
violent it almost sounds like a voice a
voice but it also yeah it feels like it
could be a stringed instrument or
something I would love just the
frequency of the sound of him hitting
the wood is what it takes to cure her
cancer
we're open on him local man this doesn't
feel like that kind of movie though
this place looks sick
yep how are you feeling about him right
now this is a fascinating character I
really like the way they've drawn him as
this guy who like you could see how
everyone's getting upset like oh man you
know you're so cocky but he just seems
burdened by a purpose and a philosophy
and not evil
keep one
guy at that moment too
[Music]
honor among Wing Chun people sure
whoa
the lens work on these fights is
fascinating
oh
this floor is amazing yeah
oh nice
these two
you called that they'd be homies let's
watch my dad beat up your dad and your
dad beat up my dad
[Music]
some wild sound design
wow
cool
[Music]
[Laughter]
I feel like hitman's always in that
black and this other guy's been in the
white and now yeah it's almost like
they've traded
that noise was intense yeah what are you
gonna move to no knives drop the knives
just bare fists man
[Music]
wow
yeah this is what we've been waiting for
oh yeah this is it let's go stop messing
around
with a good elbow yeah
wow
dang
oh
they're gonna knock each other out at
some point
[Music]
wow
oh
no bueno
whoa
oh
my God
the wattage parts
oh put that in your pocket for Bruce Lee
oh my God
is he calling it over
I don't know I think he's yeah he's
really going it over oh my God
yoga
[Music]
but then he's double defeated who's the
love of his life his kid his kid It's
gotta be his disciple maybe he'll
finally call him son
oh
same way to do this Montage yeah
greatest hits of their love a very music
video like slideshow music video-esque I
do appreciate this I mean if she's if
the character is gonna die I mean and
she's been like we've loved her so much
throughout the year why do you keep
saying if she's
learned to accept understood such denial
you don't take this from me you said
fighting's gonna bring her back it is
oh 1960.
damn
the one fight he couldn't win yeah
oh
[Music]
damn
there's another winner man
seriously I know but that one left you
uh oh
you're good oh yeah I mean I'm a little
drained but I'm good
no I mean that was that was gripping and
epic and and touching and emotional and
yeah and it didn't go it didn't go the
places I was expecting in terms of like
you know the big bads and the and like I
feel like the other two movies you have
a much more clear set of like historical
circumstances where it's like okay the
Japanese and it's like you know first
you got squabbling schools and then the
Japanese invade then you have to deal
with that tyranny and then you move to
Hong Kong and we've got you know the
British who are exercising their own
form of tyranny here and then in this
one like I thought it was gonna grow to
like okay Mike Tyson and whatever this
sort of mob Arrangement is that you know
is clearly controlling this area and you
know inhibiting the law and things like
that like I thought it was gonna be like
oh he's gonna have to fight Mike Tyson
at the end for you know some kind of you
know liberation from this you know mob
tyranny and then for it to become a much
more personal thing after that I thought
was really interesting the Mike Tyson
thing was interesting because he was
barely in the movie and also it was
um the one like draw essentially right I
feel like that probably was very
strictly contractually speaking
um which is fine because it's not like
he just tried uh distracts me it or it
doesn't detract from the movie yeah but
he really had nothing to do with the
overarch the overall like themes of the
movie which the guy at the end I don't
remember what his name is the guy that I
liked the whole time yeah Chung Chung he
was just so different than our other
our other antagonists because he's not
evil he's not trying to take over the
country or the city you know and you can
see him dealing with the circumstances
of what life is like here now too yeah
like I loved that they have him
I don't think a wild card is exactly the
right descriptor but you have him you
know at first falling in with uh this
this gang at the Western Union who you
know is clearly trying to Stranglehold
the community and then you know he sees
you know the the the
error in that I mean like At first yeah
it's means to an end I gotta feed my kid
and and I like that they don't give you
too much backstory on him you can kind
of fill in the blank based on how he
behaves what his relationship with his
son is like how he's trying to provide
um but yeah watching him
go in with them at first and then
realize like oh no they're locking kids
up and stuff and this is really this is
truly you know evil immoral and evil and
heinous yeah and I can't stand for that
and and how could I be an honorable
Master how could I you know arise to the
station and to the reputation I want to
hold if I'm you know a Lackey in this
organization completely his whole thing
is he's trying to be the best right he
just wants to be the best at what he
does and provide for his kid so it's
when you look at it like that knowing
that he was under the same thumb that um
Ip Man had been under previously you
know he lived a whole life before this
moment as well yeah you feel for him and
you realize like he this is a single
father trying to provide for his kid
through really tough times yeah and and
show that he represents this this
schooling that he has gone through
um and it man's fighting his own
separate battle Which is less of a
financial battle at this point more of a
internal Battle of do I help the
community do I help my family do I help
the community to help my family and then
ultimately that decision is made for him
when he finds out that his wife is sick
yeah yeah of course and like the way
they Incorporated that too like the way
this does go from being the kind of Ip
Man movie you're not used to in a bad
way but it's like you know it feels like
The Logical next step in it man you know
series and then to shift into something
much more sort of quietly dramatic and
much more emotionally impactful I
thought was a nice contrast like I I
could almost imagine people being taken
aback at first by that but yeah going
from these two movies where you
culminate in these big public battles to
then just this last portion where this
guy has his whole own rise on the side
and then you're just watching as you
know it man and his wife make up for
lost time and just like the the
beautiful like I like that they brought
in some new uh New Wave feeling
flourishes to that where you are just
kind of watching them dance and watching
them live a little bit and revisiting
these moments that we have spent so much
time on and and eat rice as a family
like have dinner together because it has
not been making it home for dinner
things like that yeah and like the way
that they don't really have to get in
your face with a dramatic like you're
never here you're always fighting other
people's battle even though it's there
and even though you can feel the impact
and the weight of it and the sort of
difficulty of like the all the things we
love about Ip Man probably make him kind
of a difficult husband I would imagine
right definitely I was thinking that
during the movie like should some of the
best people in the world not have
families because they are so altruistic
and dedicated to society
um and I don't believe that about it man
because I think he obviously did such an
amazing job especially about finding
that balance yeah but it has got to be
very hard when you put upon yourself the
well-being of thousands because he
really does of all of the in every
single movie is of his whole town of its
all the children it's of all the
students it's all you know like it's all
the people yeah and and sometimes that
means that you don't get to put your
loved ones first and sometimes that puts
your loved ones in a difficult position
as we see happens here like you know his
kid gets taken strategically his wife is
placed in danger like when you are a
visible public figure the way that this
guy is and you happen to inhabit a world
where fighting and having to defend the
honor of your Technique is a frequent
thing like yes it's got to be a kind of
scary life to live if you're anybody but
that guy completely completely I feel
like the the general message and I
talked about this a little throughout
the movie but like you know they say um
man makes plans God laughs or whatever I
think the general message of this is
like you can train your entire life you
can train to win every single fight and
you're still going to be handed a fight
that you cannot win it's an unwinnable
fight and that is what happened here
especially for the time period you know
now we hear cancer and you don't hear
you don't think like goner back then as
yes it's not as as much of like an
immediate like oh no there's not really
anything we can do then you go into
fight mode but back then it you go into
live mode like okay we only have so few
time left we have to live we're trying
what we can and in the meantime while we
still have it yeah we have to make the
most of this right and and I think that
that's got to be very very challenging
for somebody who has won every single
fight of his life sure and she's watched
him protect the family and win every
single fight and there's nothing he can
do yeah
yeah like it's it's a really well drawn
character portrait and I like that after
you know I'm surprised and pleased that
after three installments it still feels
I mean we've heard mixed things about
the fourth movie still very excited to
check it out but these three here have
flowed very nicely as just the what
feels authentically like the
continuation of a life and even though
they do get more heightened in ways
tonally stylistically it still feels
natural for the world that they've drawn
I still feel like I'm somewhat peering
into history even though yes there is
um you know the cultural propaganda
element that people have pointed out a
little in the comments and height for
you know things that are heightened and
fantasized for movies anyway at the end
here though it did it seemed to imply
that the real it man lost his wife to
cancer correct oh yeah I feel like the
all these main like the big major beats
are probably all real things I don't
know if he was necessarily like involved
with this mob or whatever like certain
things yeah I would be curious to know
the reality of or is Mike Tyson based on
a real guy or is this just an an
opportunity like even that like I I
appreciate the way they used him I'm
kind of curious and interested by The
Format and structure of this movie as a
whole because they do set you up to
think like okay he's gonna be kind of
like the the Twister guy from part two
um and that is maybe the one fight in
the movie that does feel like Mike
Tyson's interested in being here with
let's have him in the movies let's do a
fight you know totally but it didn't
distract me I am looking right now at
the the Netflix cover of the Ip Man 3
and that's Mike Tyson on the right right
yeah that's interesting it's like he's
really I mean like how many days could
have been on set yeah I feel like they
could have knocked that out in like a
day or two yeah you know and especially
I know that they do different approaches
for you know this well documented in
America you know shooting action takes
longer there's a lot more uh protocols
and and things to you know make the
process as safe as possible whereas in
you know Hong Kong Cinema and Chinese
Cinema and stuff like that you are kind
of just like running and gunning and
working faster hitting harder moving
faster in these fights so I probably bet
he could have knocked it out in a day or
two do you think this was to gain an
American audience
I'm sure that was part of it I would
imagine I mean like the way the creators
are just big Tyson fans could be could
be and maybe Mike Tyson expressed some
kind of Interest like I would be in feel
free if you guys made it to this point
in the video uh like Enlighten us as to
I'm sure they know at home they're like
what happened to us please yeah yeah
here's how he came to be in the movie
but like I I like that even though it
does feel like oh here's a crossover
potential it's just not like a lurid
placement you know it doesn't feel like
oh let's stop the movies so that we can
have a special guest or something like
that like I I thought even though yeah
he doesn't really
add a ton yeah he doesn't really add
like a huge amount and he's not like the
main focus of you know the movie or he's
not the main antagonist I still thought
that like the way they used him was kind
of interesting in a way that bolstered
the movie rather than taking away from
it again like the structure and the
things I was expecting not ultimately
paying off the way I had expected I
think worked well for me let me ask you
a question I know that there's a fourth
one but as it stands right now as a
Trilogy the one two three that we have
seen do you feel like this is one of the
best trilogies yeah this has been so
consistent I I think this is a a
beautiful Trilogy thus far I mean it's
each movie has had I mean you know you
never forget the first time and sort of
learning with the first movie just how
this movie is going to express itself
how these movies are going to express
themselves but uh yeah remarkably
consistent and uh and if you asked me to
rank him I would be like that's what I
was just thinking about like because all
the jump you kind of think one has to be
first right but my feeling walking out
of two was so strong and then I just
feel like the full circle aspect of and
the emotional side and the relationship
side of this one is so strong I don't
know they're so very even
very all if somebody said to me my
favorite man is it man three I wouldn't
say what no I mean I could see like
depending on the day I could see any of
them being a favorite because it's like
the first movie you have obviously the
the breadth of excitement and fresh air
just like wow Donnie and as amazing as
this character the fights and all that
tonal shift that we weren't expecting
yeah the first one it's like you get
that shift into like oh damn this is a
historical drama of sorts and then the
second one you still have that but it's
like okay now you've got Samo hung here
and now you've got a different
antagonist and you've got you know
something that sort of builds but seems
like it's a bit more heightened uh than
the previous one you've got returning
characters and that kind of of to heart
and the experience and then with part
three you have what amounts to something
much more intimate while still you know
incorporating some of those elements and
with a couple returning characters again
maybe more gray yeah yes black and white
yeah totally like each one has its
distinct flavor and thus far I think
they've each delivered on great fights
uh really interesting and poised
directing both in those fights and the
way the cinematography has grown like
here with you know there's that above
tracking shot on one fight there are the
various little zooms and and ways that
they've enhanced just the capturing of
the choreography yeah it's it's wild
because for me I'm not I'm not not a
fight fan but I'm not like I don't seek
out fight movies so the fact that
there's in all three Ip Man so far
there's never been one fight that we've
watched that I was like I wish this
wasn't happening right now could we get
back to the story that's never happened
for me every fight feels fresh and
different and Justified and that's but
like wild to me yeah and and yeah it's
like you know if the movie as a whole
isn't working even great action can get
a little mind-numbing and thus far
that's never happened and for me in one
of these movies we'll see what happens
in full I know I mean I'm still rooting
for I feel like for my guess is that
four is probably fine because maybe
noticeably not as great as this Trilogy
thus far but who knows this doesn't have
his wife to hold him down I wonder about
that I mean because she even though she
is the most prominent in terms of at
least just time focused you know in this
movie right yeah I mean I feel like
things will be different he'll have his
kids older I don't know how Bruce Lee
will factor into the next one and I
liked here that because because so much
of what you hear going into IP man is
like oh he's the master who trained
Bruce Lee and so you imagine or I
imagined that like oh so Bruce Lee is
gonna be a big part of these movies and
he appears a couple times here I like
that they kept that thread going of like
he's still trying to convince him and
that whole line about like I didn't open
the door I think what he meant by that
was like I opened the door to
communicate that my door is always open
not for you to leave
at the time of that happened I said to
you so is that a no and you're like yeah
it seems like a no but to me I didn't
take it as a no and then when he later
on clarifies and says like you
misunderstood or whatever I was thinking
like oh
you got it uh-huh
that's the second time of the first time
I did you would have been a quicker
study than old Bruce Lee yeah that's
what I'm saying pretty much
um faster I would get those cigarettes
and chop the water that see that and
like you know they're great fights with
weapons they're great fights with
different sets and things like that but
even that with the cigarettes I thought
was was something that like could be
silly it is a little cheeky but it's
part of too like even though there are
so many kind of harsh and intense
elements of these movies there are still
really Charming
small flourishes of humor or of just
human personality and uh yeah I thought
that was really fun and clever I'm with
you to me the elevator fight and the
boat fight really stand out like as two
that were like whoa this is new yeah
definitely and and like I love that even
still they seem very inspired and
invigorated to come up with these again
just different ways of showing the array
of you know applications of Wing Chun
and and two yeah having it come down to
a fight between them that is only one
audience member who's not even watching
directly plus the kids
um but yeah having just like this really
intimate fight at the end with these big
long staffs and these blades ultimately
coming down to just the fists and then
seeing I thought that was fun they they
do the nod to the one inch punch the
Bruce Lee punch that's the ultimate move
that finishes him I think that's what
that's supposed to be uh and so like
that was a nice way to keep that
presence that sort of fun
I I hesitate to call it an Easter egg
but you could it's it's a Bruce leester
egg at least there's Easter egg Yeah man
so like you know I thought that was a
nice way to keep his presence as part of
this even though yeah you know he's not
like in the fights and he's like he's in
the dancing scene I was like I love
those little subversions too like these
are just so like kind of alive in the
way that they're thought out because I
feel like you could easily kind of
autopilot the stories on these if you
wanted to because the fights are so
great and the cast is so great like it's
the other thing is I'm always like man
it's like
so lucky that Donnie Yen and everybody
involved are such good Fighters but also
can act yeah yeah yeah totally because
if they couldn't then it would be a
disaster you know it was good because
you barely had any coffee to stay awake
and fall asleep like last time oh yeah
that's what happens falling asleep man
movies it's just not not exciting enough
for my American eyes
yeah and I've never I don't know who I
believe the actor's name is uh Jin Zhang
who played uh uh Chung but uh like he I
thought had a lot of presence and and oh
my God he was so good yeah I like the
kids too they're very subtle and natural
yeah absolutely it's so nice man this is
really really lovely thanks for doing
this with me man thank you this has been
no this has been such a cool and
wonderful Journey I'm very glad we've
been able to bond over this yeah me too
this is one of those things that was
like so unexpected then when Greg was
like I'm pairing you and Roxy up for it
man I was like okay yeah okay okay I
have along for the ride and then yeah
and then every time he's like I got Roxy
coming in and I'm like another rip man
he's like yeah I'm like all right let's
go like so you have to text him this
next time and say that you watched four
you couldn't wait so you have to respond
Roxy's just gonna have to do it alone he
just couldn't wait man sorry it needed
it that bad absolutely I just I you know
that's me man I'm not a considerate
person you'll find oh I am very selfish
I know I have learned nothing from these
movies yeah that's very Mike Tyson in
this movie it's my role model
Frank that's right man
he does look like a Frank with his face
tattoo he for sure does not you know uh
maybe who who knows who could show up
here Jimbo
yeah
Jimbo or like um or a Craig
hi Craig I could see Craig Cobra Bubbles
[Laughter]
what was the deal with the girl with the
balloon and the mom you know I think
it's just one of those contrast pieces
of like I guess that's his his uh Hong
Kong honey and uh yeah like I guess he's
they're just used to him fighting people
and that was her daughter and therefore
he he cared about that okay I couldn't
tell if that was his actual like family
here or if he was just like dating this
girl who already had a kid yeah or
something like that he seemed to care at
least I don't know they just were like
we're not gonna flush this out or flush
this out and that's fine
there was a lot of like little
interstitials even with characters who
aren't like derive just incidental
characters that just kind of fleshed out
the life of people living you know at
the time so I thought that was kind of
one of those things I don't know I guess
this is what Frank's life is about when
he's not busy being a uh you know a
Kingpin like what do you feel like
happened to him I don't know honestly
like it feels like he probably was just
able to continue about his business you
think they were trying to leave the door
open for him in four could be then he's
not in four right no idea oh like yeah
well I guess we'll find out yeah we'll
be able to react to that I don't think
I've ever heard you the one two however
you do them how do you do four
four
I'll only get it when it doesn't matter
when it comes time to say for in a in a
way that like is in the moment for the
intro or something then you know when I
need it to work it won't work but when I
try to imitate you I do Count Dracula
which is not it Avon
that's how I talk okay I in fact I'm
flattered this is if anybody had to do
an impression of me I'm glad that
Dracula is where it goes first
I've got you and I'm the most flattered
by that Prospect you're welcome but hey
guys if you've got an impression of me
leave it down below in the comments or
record it and then send it to me and
I'll grade you uh for accuracy and Roxy
will grade you too and if it doesn't
sound like The Count from Sesame Street
then you're probably not on the right
track but Roxanne do you have any other
thoughts before we get the hell out of
here just so far so good man so far so
great yeah
dude and props to uh Lin shung who plays
uh Wing sing she is so good so like and
I feel like stare at her she's just like
Perfection human she is so poised in
love yeah and like throughout these like
I love that they really gave so much of
this movie to her because she has been
such a beautiful presence in the last
two coming into this behind every
fighter this is is a tremendous you know
steady graceful woman if you're lucky if
you're lucky yeah hey Master Chung so
for all of you at home with graceful
women you think you're lucky stars yeah
and you know you sew their buttons on
for them instead of asking them to sew
the butt on for real so the buttons on
your damn self but also for everybody
with an IP man at home you think you're
lucky stars too yeah yeah yeah be
thankful of each other and speaking of
thankfulness yes let's let's be thankful
for a page
I love the chase all right Chase Gardner
Roxy loves the chase so shout out Chase
Garner what do you guys say Chase
Gardner you're the only uh thing I want
to chase I don't actually want to chase
other things except for you okay see
that oh you could be his wing yeah see
the good thing about the name Chase
Gardner too is that Gardener dope yeah
chase you gotta be fast yeah probably a
very Speedy guard that is a good you
lucked out on the name combo there yeah
well something says it's not luck that
gets your name
people that make you yeah and they give
you the name
well but it's still luck to you yeah
that's true that's true it's not luck to
them because they just came up they just
pulled it out of nowhere but yeah yeah
you know but Chase Mass C and plus it
works both ways master chase sounds cool
Master Gardener also sounds cool master
chase Gardener Chase man Chase man yes I
wish people would call me John man
[Music]
rocks man rocks man
it didn't work as well it's okay we'll
Workshop it we got one more movie at
least and then we got to move on to
other martial arts I guess I guess
that'll be our theme is just martial
arts movie that's all we can do now well
Chase we love you stay pledged and keep
walking that righteous path keep
fighting the good fight and uh thank you
when you're ready to open up your school
we'll come train with you oh yeah
be sexy gardening School gardening
School in a cross-country as well
cross-country and gardening yeah
obviously they go very well together
love you buddy see you next time
good
[Music]